this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Applause]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality host of the
fine print podcast is my co-host today
as we take your calls about your
relationships your money your work your
career your life it's all happens right
here on the ramsey show it's a free call
and some say the advice is worth exactly
what you pay for it the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five marcy is in seattle
washington hey marcy welcome to the
ramsey show
um hi thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
um i have a question about long-term
care insurance
um my husband and i purchased policies a
few months ago
to avoid a
state run
program that we thought was going to be
implemented as of january 1st
um that has since been delayed until at
least april of this year but it's
looking like it's going to be pushed out
even further like till july of 2023
so we're wondering if we should keep the
policies that we have
um they are not
um the best
long-term care insurance policy that we
probably probably could have gotten you
just wanted something cheap to keep your
communist government from taxing you
exactly thank you yeah
yes the state of washington has lost its
freaking mind
yeah
it's it was a ridiculous um act and
there's so many flaws in it and that's
why there's all these bills being
proposed now to try and delay it and fix
some of the
the flaws i wish somebody put in from
the supreme court and just stomp on it
but uh but you know in the meantime we
real people out here have to deal with
this crap so i i wouldn't drop it if
you're gonna turn around and buy it
again in april but if you don't have to
buy it until june of 23 then yes i would
drop it so i guess i'm probably tapping
the brakes and just watch see what
happens if they kick it in in april you
got to turn on bite again right
uh yes yeah to avoid it yeah and that's
a lot of trouble and so i'd probably
just sit on it for a month or two here
and then if they do kick the can on down
the road to june i'd drop it
how old are you okay
um
i'm 49 and my husband's 54. but they're
required by state law to carry it now if
they don't they get a tax hmm correct
regardless of age what are you paying
every month have you kind of shopped
this around to at least make sure that
you're yeah you're getting a good deal
yeah we well
initially we didn't because in the there
was sort of a frenzy of people trying to
get policies in place so we just grabbed
whatever we could um but we're paying
for combined my husband and i um about
200 a month for our policy the state tax
would would be about half of that
um but it for
its garbage coverage
and um and then we i did actually um a
couple of weeks ago speak to one of your
elps for that specializes in long-term
care
uh insurance policies um and he said for
for about the same prices that we're
paying right now for
a universal life policy with a
long-term care writer he could
get us a policy i'm sorry you said one
of my elps told you that no no no no
he could he could
offer us a better policy
so one that fits within you know your
guidelines and everything not a
universal life policy but that would be
a similar cost basically equivalent to
what we're paying right now for okay
well if you would rather change any way
then you could drop this wait till april
figure it out or wait of the following
june and figure it out and go to the one
you're changing to if you're going to
change any way that changes the answer
so it sounds like you bought the
universal life one and you do need to
drop that so yeah go ahead and drop it
now and then in april you've if you have
to rebuy
to avoid the tax uh you can do that
again how many states require one oh one
okay she lucked out by living so far
well i mean
they're just
complete
bonkers yeah i mean it's just you you
pass a law that if you don't carry
long-term care insurance you have to pay
a tax the equivalent of the cost of
long-term care insurance because the
state is going to have to pay
part of medicaid if you go into the
nursing home and it's just straight-up
socialism i mean it's just classic
uh but this is the reason people are
running out of some of these states is
their taxation and their and their
social policies are both just dr people
are leaving by the
literally by the truckloads
so i'm leaving the coast yeah it's um
they're coming to tennessee well yeah
yeah
uh the the latest one i saw was please
don't be a missionary just be a refugee
that's good meaning don't bring your
stupid vote with you if you come
so um i i've tried to get the tennessee
state legislature to pass a law that if
you move here from california you can't
vote for two years or until you've been
through indoctrination on what what
potentially running an economy looks
like but um
but they haven't picked me up on that i
haven't responded to your email yeah
it's not not answered me on that one so
can you imagine why i think it went to
spam yeah yeah it went to that uh i'm in
that other file a special folder for you
the special folder for dave that's it
that's so
sharon is in atlanta georgia hi sharon
welcome to the ramsay show
hi how are y'all today great what's up
nothing much um i just had a quick
question for you um i've heard your name
sprinkled out throughout my life um but
about a month ago i really started
listening and i just recently purchased
your um babystep millionaire's book i'm
on chapter 5 i believe thank you but um
i i was very blessed in the way that i
was brought up and i don't really um
i have my mortgage and that's that's it
um
but i also realized in doing my budget
last night that i tend to
micromanage my money and i don't have
any money left over to have fun with
and that tends to get me into trouble
then you'll go have fun and it wasn't
budgeted
right right yeah and um made a couple of
stupid decisions in my life and um
so anyway we're um so i technically
should be in baby step four five and six
but i haven't done like one two or three
well you don't have one you don't have
to if you have no debt and you have your
emergency fund in place then you're in
four five and six you don't have to
start at one
okay
well um i was wondering if you can tell
me like
is there is there another book i should
be reading should i be talking to like a
financial person
um
i mean i'd love to go ahead and send you
a copy of the total money makeover
that's going to be a detailed uh plan to
walk you through all these baby steps
the ins and outs but right now in four
through six you're focused on paying off
the house and make sure you're budgeting
for some fun you know we say there's
three things you can do with money give
save spend so give some save some for
those future goals that you have invest
15 of your income and beyond that you're
saving for college you're paying off the
house and enjoying life so start
budgeting for that
[Music]
that's exactly what i would do trying to
think what to add to that
wow nailed it first try drop mic drop
it's a good day it's all downhill from
here micro moon's full this is the
ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the ramsey show george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host we just got word
this morning that uh
the book baby steps millionaires is the
number one book in the nation
thank you
thank you guys all of you that's pretty
good he hit a bunch of categories didn't
it number one overall number one
non-fiction number one business i mean
it's slayed and the reason reason is
slate is two things one is the number of
people that
listen to the show and that are
interacting with us on different things
nationally thank you guys for trusting
us and for
for purchasing it and i i i the promise
that i made with the book is true
and it will do that for you if you'll
follow it how ordinary people build
extraordinary wealth and how you can too
and our team i mean you don't do a
number one anything
in this world
without an uh herculean effort
uh with a whole lot of uh very very
dedicated people um
you know i used to be so dumb i thought
if you just wrote a really good book
that mattered that all of a sudden it
would just go and it would work no you
have to actually go do the marketing you
have to actually do the distribution you
have to handle all the publicity i've
done
so many interviews in the past three
weeks i'm exhausted it's wonderful i've
had a good time being back with a lot of
the shows that i hadn't been on in a
long time and
um because this is the first book i've
done a major trade book in eight years
and so but um thank you guys on our team
all the work you've done on this show
and all the other shows and things we've
we do around the marketing team the
publicity team the publishing team and
um
and all of you guys that bought it thank
you uh we appreciate the trust we're
honored by that we
uh work real hard to be worthy of that
trust and uh
uh coming out of the shoot it's actually
i've had a bunch of number ones but this
one um
kind of
destroyed it was it's uh at a different
level wow so it's really still got it
dave that's good really hot well i don't
know if i've got it but
a lot of you
wanted to know this message and that's
what matters
so we're here to help you it's what we
do and it's our opportunity to serve and
we really really appreciate it 2022 is a
fresh start this is your wake-up call
all of our books
uh or a lot of our best sellers rather
are not all of them but most of them are
on sale for ten dollars at
ramseysolutions.com right now including
the cash envelope systems are there for
ten dollars there's all kinds of
specials going on fifty to seventy
percent off right now it's new years a
lot of people need the tools in their
hands
to move on and
do that next thing you know and that
next step and that's what we're all
about around here showing you a
step-by-step plan to
get a new job from paycheck to purpose
with ken coleman to become a millionaire
following the baby steps to get out of
debt following the debt snowball
whatever it is we're helping you with we
want to help you do all of that
um you know you listen to georgia's
podcast that we did here on the ramsey
network called the fine print it's all
about showing you ways that you're
getting tripped up so that you can not
get tripped up and get to your get to
the life that you're supposed to have
that god has for you so ramsay
solutions.com backslash store check out
the store right now there's all kinds of
things going on there including the book
baby steps millionaires of course for
sale there and it is for sale most
everywhere we've had reorders now from
all the majors all the major bookstores
and all that are carrying it which means
it is off of their shelves and they've
turned around and done the second order
and that's always a good sign from the
marketing business perspective but it
also means that that you guys are
embracing this idea that you can win
today and that's what we do we sell hope
here we want to make you believe that
you can do it and show you how to do it
and then you can walk with you while you
do it and uh that's what this is all
about so it's good good times open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five rachel is with us in
l.a hi rachel welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you how are you better than i
deserve what's up good
okay so long story short i just moved in
with my best friend
we are now roommates and
i know that she's struggled financially
within the last couple years
um you know habits aren't really that
good
um
she just came to me yesterday and she
was considering filing bankruptcy
um she's just you know weighing over her
head on payments and
getting collection calls and i really
don't want her to go down that route
i bought her the total money makeover
book several years ago she never read it
and i don't want to be like
i mean she knows that i've gotten out of
debt
using your steps in the past i'm not
fully out of debt but i'm still working
on it
and i know she knows that there's help
out there but i just
i don't know how to
tell her you know
i don't want her to go that route
without overstepping boundaries you know
like she brought it up
true but i
why did she bring it up if she didn't
want your input
well it's not the first time that she's
mentioned it to me but this is the first
time
like with financial problems but this is
the first like bankruptcy like option
that she's
stated
and i just i don't really know where to
go from here i mean i've bought her the
book before do you care about this more
than she does
i think so yeah you can't help her then
and bankruptcy is not going to help her
either because she's going to get right
back in the same stupid mess again yeah
her habits they're going to stay the
same exactly
so i mean when i've got a friend that's
doing stuff like that i just ask them do
you want help if you want help i can
show you how
that you don't have to file and show you
what to do and i'm not going to shame
you i'm not going to beat you up i'll
walk with you but i'm also going to kick
your little butt while we're doing this
stuff
because you're my friend and i love you
and i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
participate in your crazy and call that
friendship that's enabling
uh-huh
right i mean this is the conversation
you have if you're my friend
i'm gonna ask permission to bust you
right and if you give me that permission
game on
if you don't i'm gonna back up and watch
the car wreck
right cause i i can't do any good i
can't help you then
yeah if you push back unsolicited it's
going to backfire and it's going to hurt
the relationship she's got to want the
help and i mean it sounds like she's
she's kind of backed against the wall
here and so you can encourage her you
can give her some resources but you
can't you know you can bring the horse
to water but you can't make them drink
and so so
i it would sound something like this
with me okay look i've been there
because you have i've been scared
confused
and beat up and beat down and it's kind
of the way you look to me right now
and i'm i'm hurting for you
um
and i want to help if you want me to
help if you want me to show you some
things if you want me to walk with you
in this i can help you or if you want me
to stand back and just watch you drive
the car in the ditch i can do that too i
i'll be whatever kind of friend whatever
level of friend you want me to be but if
you if
i understand you're scared
and if you want some help i can i can
show you some things i think that i did
that i learned when i was just like you
and so you know you're using your your
weakness
as a thing and talking about yourself
rather than wagging your finger in her
face because you don't want to get up
there and go you know you're stupid
you're an idiot don't do this that's not
that's not helpful but the bottom line
is you do need to ask in a very firm way
that you have permission to speak into
this and then it's not talking about all
her old habits it's just talking about
where we are right now we can't fix the
old things all we can figure figure out
is that so number one if you file
bankruptcy
student loans aren't bankruptable
irs is not bankruptable
anything that has a lien against it if
you want to keep it
is not bankruptable
her car
if she has debt on it you don't get to
keep it in bankruptcy unless you resign
for the debt
in which case filing for bankruptcy on
car note would be stupid if you turn
around and keep it
right right
and so a lot of people by the time they
take all the things off the table that
bankruptcy doesn't cover
really aren't filing bankruptcy on very
much they're just filing bankruptcy
because they're scared confused and
and you know caught in the middle of a
tornado
and another resource rachel i have for
you on the fine print we did a whole
episode on is bankruptcy a quick fix for
struggling americans i interviewed dave
on there about his bankruptcy story i
talked to a bankruptcy attorney we
talked to people who are on the verge of
bankruptcy and so that might be an easy
you know 30-minute listing you can do
with her or let her listen on her own
that can give her some hope that was the
goal with that episode to help people
understand what bankruptcy is what it
isn't and give them hope that there's a
way out
and so uh check that out that's the best
answer best answer on here it's
completely free it only takes 30 minutes
just go download that right now fine
print
podcast pull up the bankruptcy lesson
hand her the phone tell her to listen to
it
and then say if you need some help i'll
walk with you and if you want to get her
in touch with one of the coaches that
we've trained a ramsey trained coach
ramsey preferred coach we can walk
through it she's probably not bankrupt
she's probably just so scared and
confused and doesn't see a way out
and you can you can you can walk your
way out of anything in almost in these
situations we've done it with tens of
thousands of people
so try to get her to understand what's
going on here and just love her well
gently kindly no shaming but telling the
truth
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage mike and lindsay are
with us hey guys welcome hey dave hi
where do you guys live
hudson illinois all right and here to do
a debt-free scream yes sir how much have
you paid off
95 264. cool how long did that take um
about 48 months good and your range of
income during that time oh we started at
97 000 and we ended at 124 000. cool
what do you guys do for a living i'm in
human resources and i drive a truck for
an environmental waste company very cool
good okay great t-shirts sally may has
been evicted the other one rich people
really are scared of leaves i like it
yes sir so that side gig or is that just
a joke no that's a side gig i picked up
mowing yards and raking leaves and
that's kind of when our story got
started was uh
we were taking financial peace and i
went to the store and uh it was like a
week before right before the class yep
we had been to our first class and we're
gonna go the second one and i called her
and i said i just bought a leaf blower
and said you what we're on we're on a
budget so well i'm gonna you know blow
leaves i'm gonna make some extra money
help us speed this thing up all right we
went to class that a couple days later
yeah and you said buy yourself a leaf
blower
rich people are scared of leaves
sure enough we looked at each other in
the class when our jaws dropped
that's amazing yeah
that is so fun i love it i love it hey
way to go you guys okay so what prompted
you to get started on all this ramsey
stuff so we've been married for just
over 10 years now and on our
on our wedding someone gave us the book
we chucked it to the side and you know
use it as a coaster it's a great coaster
yeah and uh just two drinks on there
exactly so never really did anything
with it you know in and out like
listening to the show here and there and
then one day we were on vacation and
we were broke we didn't have any money
to buy food to get home you know gas to
get home or food and
just kind of broke vacation yeah i've
been on those we got back and just dug
it back out and he said it's time you
can't be davish i mean it's it's all or
nothing yeah we tried using the credit
card to book the hotel and they said you
reached your max and so we were like
vigorously trying to call and say can
you bump our limit we need you know
we're in a different town we're trying
to stay the night and you know at that
point they're like yeah you know we'll
give you more money and then we were
able to stay but that was our point
where we were like we're done we can't
do it yeah when you're begging someone
else to not be homeless yeah it was a
bad thing yeah yeah that's awful yeah so
what kind of debt was the 95 000 you
name it yeah student loans um i had nine
store credit cards in addition to like
two or three different chase cards um
cars personal loans um we had a funeral
uh payment mower um
we put a personal loan i think on the
mower yep yeah so yeah you did have
everything you had everything yeah y'all
were so normal
normal
so did you just think i'm really good at
managing these 12 credit cards
i knew exactly when you know victoria's
secret was gonna have their sale and
they're 30 off to use the card and all
that yeah i was one of those people at
the store so you had mastered being
broke yeah wow
i knew she was serious when uh she cut
those all up yeah uh oh that's good
which one was the hardest i'm just
curious which one was like sentimental
oh man there's always one
shoot i'm trying to think there's so
there's nine of them um a lot of stores
you like yeah yeah um problem probably
victoria's secret i think they throw in
the cat like not the um discount they do
like ten dollars off for twenty dollars
and obviously with money it seems like
oh i can get more money you know
a discount off more money you feel like
you were making money off the scheme
yeah yeah
and you realize nope we're actually
broke yeah i was walking out of the
store like oh i took their money i got
all the sales
so then you decide after coming home and
reading the book to go to financial
peace university yeah best thing we did
and we just had it at your church or
just a local area or yeah local church
we did twice yep okay we went through it
twice about halfway through we need a
little more motivation and yeah once you
get that motivation you start seeing the
light at the end of the tunnel i mean
it's real snowball just gets bigger and
bigger and yeah here we go yeah
you stuck with us four years 48 months
that's a stripe man i mean you went
after it yeah uh that's a lot of leaves
yeah yeah it was a lot i already quit
those jobs too by the way i bet i don't
blame you
so um
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
what's yours mine would be a why you
gotta you gotta have a why to really see
you um
my family never really had money um they
were going to the bank every you know
seemed like every other day getting more
money for this more money for that and
i don't want that for my kids
not at all
change your family tree exactly and i
don't i don't want them having college
debt like we took us forever to pay off
i don't want that for him
just change everything for him yeah i
would say definitely mine's the budget
and goals
physical i would definitely encourage
people to use physical goals we did a
chain link for the kids
and it was but you know it was but ugly
in our house but my husband's like well
stay in there until we cut every single
one off so that was my motivation to to
show each one what we cut off we let
them cut them off when we
you know had the amounts we took a video
um when we did our debt free you know in
our house
absolutely and how old are they let's
bring them up into the shot here yeah
their names and ages uh luke
is seven
and emmy is three okay fine wow so they
were participating chopping up the links
then he's got his t-shirt on my family
tree's been changed yep and hers is uh
what so much sold sold so much i thought
i was next oh that's funny
that's a good one you got all the isms
on there
i like it well done guys it's fun very
fun you guys are amazing you've done an
amazing thing here how does it feel to
be free and it feels good yeah it feels
real good yeah i'm so proud of you yeah
well done well done we've got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you number
one best seller as of today and we'll
give you a copy because that's the next
chapter in your story you're going to go
on and do that now finish up finish it
out
do change your family tree become
wealthy yeah that's the thing to do here
and be outrageously generous along the
way very cool we got a copy of total
money makeover you can give it to
someone in case they need a coaster yeah
and um because it makes a really good
one and then it appears to show up when
it comes to the right time
it's a smart bomb it just lays there
ticking until it's time right waiting
for you to be ready that's it that's the
whole thing all right mike and lindsay
luke and emmy hudson illinois 95 000
paid off in 48 months making 97 to 124
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three
two one
[Music]
[Applause]
they did not hold back
well i mean she's three and a half and
she she wins she wins the internet she's
got pipes man she she busted it way to
go
way to go emmy you're a star that's
amazing luke ain't bad either i mean he
yelled as big as his hat there if you're
listening on radio go watch it on
youtube because you can't see that was
amazing wow this is what it looks like
when you change your family tree yeah
they're never gonna they have this
that's dialed into their memory you
can't get rid of it now yeah that time
that my dad
got a leaf blower yep and my mom and
they worked extra and i cut the chains
with my
butt ugly thing in our house and the
time i remember being a little bitty kid
cutting that up and they can tell their
grandkids that yeah
that's what a family tree being changed
is it's not just the money it's not just
the math you get out of debt you've got
the math to change your life you have to
become a millionaire you got all that
working but but more importantly you
completely dial in a whole new
financial dna imprint on the kiddos they
you know mom and dad don't borrow money
oh wait wait wait we're ramsey's we
don't borrow money it's like a foreign
thing no of course oh no
there's a lot of things ramses don't do
and that's one of we don't borrow money
i mean can you imagine rachel cruz
i could totally see that and please she
said more is caught than taught you know
from smart money smart kids it's an
imprint this is what's happening they
saw this whole experience they got to be
a part of it and now they get to live a
very different life because of it and uh
and they will and because now they're
going to live out the rest of their
childhood watching these principles
become
cause their parents to become wealthy
yeah and and then that finishes off the
job of the
parenting part of the equation that
legacy it's it's such an incredible why
to have when you can go man what would
it be like to be able to pay for my
grandkids college would it be like to be
the last ramsey
and this branch of the tree the last one
that had death wow the last one that had
to call and beg some stupid butt idiot
on the other end of the phone on a
credit card company to raise my limits
or have a place to stay i'm the last one
by god never again you gotta have that
you gotta have that moment man gotta
have it this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
tanya's in denver hey tanya what's up
hi dave um congratulations on your book
reaching number one thank you
i did pick up a copy well it's all your
fault then we appreciate you
yeah i have a question for you about
investment strategy i typically do a
backdoor raw me too um however i heard
you say that potentially that poll is
looking to be closed um and so for this
is there concern
about doing that back door conversion
for this tax year and are you
recommending people hold off on doing
that or not i did mine
yesterday okay
um it was part of the buildback america
bill that failed
right uh but my comment i think in
addition that you may have heard was
that um that i do think someday it's
going to be addressed the the loophole
it is literally a loophole i mean it's
not illegal it's not immoral but it is
um
it's a loophole and so um i think one of
these days somebody in a piece of
legislation is going to tack that on the
end of it
but
if they want to stay with the rich
people must be punished narrative
that generally comes out of the income
tax system
so what would be your recommendation
like if and when that does close as
another alternative um well i mean
that's close so you just got to do other
investing obviously i mean i buy yeah i
mean
that's only it's only eight thousand
dollars i mean there's only so much you
can do anyway but
me and sharon so uh the uh i in addition
to that i do low turnover mutual funds
and i buy real estate that i pay cash
for
okay you know what a low turnover mutual
fund is
yeah as long as they don't change what's
inside of it very often right so there's
no taxation on it until you sell it to
amount anything
yep because it's basically capital gains
growth like buying a single stock that
goes up you don't pay taxes on the
increase until you sell it
same thing and so it gives you this it
gives you a
tax deferred
growth in a sense and it's capital gains
growth at that which is wonderful
meaning you get tax capital gains rate
rather than ordinary income rate
so
it's a good question for these high
income earners where they go all right i
can do my 401k i'm not eligible for the
roth ira i can do a back door roth let's
explain the roth the back door roth yeah
so for a high income earner make over
200 000 a year household income there
there is a loophole to where you can
turn it into a roth by contributing on
the traditional side after tax exactly
so you're not allowed to do a roth ira
if you make over 200 a year household
income
so what you can do is call a back door
roth and this is the loophole that we're
talking about is you can open and you
can always roll regardless of your
income things into a roth
you can always roll to a run it's on the
traditional side you can pay the
conversation if you've got anything in
there if you're willing to pay the
conversion then you're going to have
that
so anything that you
no matter what your income is you can
roll stuff to a roth you can roll an old
401k an old ira into a roth and then if
it was traditional then the amount of
gain or amount that's in it would be
taxable at that point now if you open an
after tax
meaning there was not taxes held out it
was it's after the tax already been held
out of the money
i uh traditional ira
and instantaneously roll it to a roth
there's no taxes and that's called a
back door roth ira and i do one every
year for me and one every year for my
wife it's not a lot of money but it's
that much more that i can get into tax
free growth the other thing and that's
what you you only do that kind of stuff
at baby step seven
and beyond and if you're a
high income earner the other thing that
people do a lot and i do this as well is
the match at your company
is not allowed to be roth it has to be
traditional
and so once a year
i roll
all of my match from my company into the
roth
and pay the taxes on that that that is
tax that does create taxes but i roll it
all to roth and pay the taxes on it and
roll it all to roth and pay taxes on it
so years ago i've converted everything
into roth so all of the money that is in
the retirement former seps former iras
former 401ks everything anything you've
got like that outstanding when i reached
baby step seven i had
extra money
then i would roll stuff to roth pay the
taxes because that tax in a sense
becomes an additional investment into it
because it grows tax-free from then on
yeah and that's the goal is to have all
this money uh without uncle sam's hands
on it ever again when you withdraw that
exactly and it's growing tax-free so all
the growth i get between now and death
is completely tax-free
and uh and you know an inherited ira on
a roth there's no taxes so uh it because
it's a cause it's a roth and so it
cleans up your estate plan in that
regard too and beyond that beyond all
the tax advantage tax deferred
retirement accounts things like that
then we move into taxable investments
where you're just gonna pay you know
your capital gains rate and all that but
that can be a great option for those
high income earners and a lot of people
do this to retire early you kind of have
that bridge account where you go i'm
going to live off this taxable
investment until i can pull out from my
retirement exactly a low turnover and a
lot of ways to get an easy way to get to
a low turnover
easy way to find something with a five
percent or less turnover ratio is the s
p 500 index fund no commission
i dump money in those uh
additional spillover money so to speak
in those all the time and i it and it
you know i'll leave it if i leave it
there a year before i take it out
whatever growth is going to be taxed at
ordin i mean at capital gains rate which
in my case is more than 15
but it's still less than my full
complete over taxation i'm just about to
puke when i look at what we're going to
pay this year but
uh chris is in new york city hey chris
welcome to the ramsey show
hey guys thanks for taking my call
um i had a quick question for you so my
wife and i are currently renting our
home from family
and have just considered buying a home
in florida i wanted to make our primary
residents split our time
between where we're currently at because
all of our family is here
but get away from the winters also
wanted to start building some equity in
this property
homestead the property for income tax
purposes because
i'm self-employed um while we don't have
a mortgage my only debt is a school loan
which will be paid off in november
otherwise
you know
that's kind of where we're at so i
wanted to get some insight
find out so you're 50 50 between new
york and florida
that would be the goal yes yep
okay what's your household income
uh between 275 and 300 um a year so it
really depends on the year but um i mean
you're really right on the line of 50
50. you're not talking about 90 10
yeah
yeah because we're young and our whole
family is is uh where we currently live
um
if you're not half the year
yeah right but you know we're looking to
get into the sunshine a little bit and
uh maybe away from the winter you know
for
six months in a day if that makes sense
well yeah it makes a lot of sense to get
out of new york taxes
yeah
but uh so um i guess my dilemma is you
know i'm in a unique situation where i
do get a little bit of help on the
school loan on a monthly basis
um what do you mean by that four grand a
month at that uh i have um you know a
family member um giving me a little bit
of money you know as part of my um deal
towards towards the school loan oh i'm
sorry i didn't know you still had debt i
apologize i didn't get that
how much do you have much do you own in
november okay i would pay that off don't
buy a second house till you pay your
student loan off you have 40 grand in
debt
40 000 in uh in school on that 2.99 i
don't care what the interest and you
make 300 000 yeah why is this not paid
off in two months
this past year was the first year i
earned that prior to that okay um it was
far less than that you need to clean
that up and you need to have a strong
emergency fund before we start talking
about buying a second house
when you're renting right now yeah
yeah would you continue to rent i do
have go ahead guys would you continue to
rent in new york and then you'd purchase
a home in florida
correct okay
yeah i would get out of debt then this
is your home purchase is what it amounts
to with your new income and your new
plan and so i'll be out of debt have an
emergency fund and have a good strong
down payment for the florida home
purchase before you do it so it sounds
like it's going to be a year before you
get around to that but use this income
do not let this income flow it away i
know this is new income and you may be
tempted to spend it all do not you could
get crazy and you could pay cash with
this kind of income so use it wisely you
could you could put a big chunk down on
this house in a year and be debt-free
and have an emergency fund and then get
it paid off within a couple of years in
florida and that does change the whole
equation take advantage of that big
shovel good stuff cool
hey thanks for the call chris
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host george campbell ramsey
personality host of the fine print
podcast on ramsey networks is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five as we talk
about your relationships we talk about
your work and your career we talk about
your money and we talk about you it is
the ramsey show triple eight eight two
five five
five we are celebrating uh news that we
got this morning that the book baby
steps millionaires uh has debuted as a
number as a number one bestseller in the
nation thank you guys all of you that
bought it we appreciate you
and uh very much and we're going to keep
our promises that the book will do the
things we told you it would do if you do
the things in the book that we told you
that you should do how ordinary people
built extraordinary wealth and how you
can two that's what it's all about so
again open phones here at triple eight
eight two five five two two five brad's
in phoenix hey brad how are you
i'm okay how are you dave better than i
deserve what's up in your world
okay so i've been married 32 years i'm
going through a divorce
that's not going to get fixed um and i
have two options the way i've been
looking at it the wife has a lawyer i
have a lawyer
i can take fifty percent of her pension
which would be seventeen hundred dollars
a month
uh
our house appraised at six hundred fifty
thousand i think it's a little high but
uh the parade's at six fifty we owe
ninety
i make eighty a year uh that's without
half of her pension my option a is
uh which she said she might honor even
though her lawyer is probably not going
to want her to honor it would be i give
her a hundred thousand cash and she
walks away from the house and i don't
touch your pension option b which my
lawyer says i should definitely do
is to
definitely take 50 percent of her
pension which should be 1700 a month but
then i have to pay her 230 000 cash
which means i have to refinance my home
so i'm not sure which way to go where's
the hundred thousand coming from if you
did option a
uh
a gift if you will
my father might probably help me out or
i could just simply refinance 100 grand
out of my equity
i see
but everybody keeps telling me do not
walk away from that pension because
if she dies before me that pension will
keep paying out at least that's how it's
written up um
she may want to change that and say no
when i die bradley is not getting
anything else and i think that's how
it's written up now but my lawyer is
going to argue saying
the only way brad's going to
honor taking your pension is if
it keeps paying whether kathy creed
deceases you or not
yeah
so
right now it sounds good give her 100
grand i'm sitting on a 650 000 house now
i owe
almost 200
i could rent it out sell it do whatever
that would always be a good nest egg for
me
but everybody's telling me definitely
take half of her pension because that's
constant income that you don't have to
worry about
what do you do for a living
a security technician
um
a friend of mine that does divorce
recovery says that divorce turns a
marriage into a business transaction
and that's what it's
that's what you're doing you were very
calculated and
walking through this um how long has
this been going on
uh the marriage has been kind of on the
rocks for the past 10 years i mean how
long was this divorce declared and you
got lawyers how long ago was that uh we
started she filed for divorce late
october okay and we have a meeting on
monday to
it's not the final decree or whatever
you call it but it's a meeting saying
here's what kathy wants here's a bread
once and the judge says okay get your
stuff together and come back to me with
a decision yeah we were going to go
through just a mediator but
i wanted to play it safe and got a
lawyer which i'm already eight thousand
dollars that's okay you need to do that
there's someone there's a lot of money
involved here and you need a lawyer
um you did the right and you know the
other side of this is uh she keeps
saying that uh you know by me taking
hyper pension i'm going to be broke i
got to find an apartment yada yada i
understand that
the best department we can find for her
and her lifestyle is going to be about
1500 a month
but i got a feeling she's all also got a
little nest egg from an old boyfriend
that's going to inherit about 25 million
dollars i gotta find he's going to take
care of her in some fashion also so but
i'm putting all my social things aside
and looking at this as a strict business
transaction
it's hard to do
yeah it's hard to separate the finances
of the emotions because what i'm seeing
is if you take half her pension it's
gonna create this weird tension where
you're still intertwined in her life and
so the part i like about the other one
is
you got kids
all grown up out of the house
grandkids
negative
okay
um mathematically
i would do option a a hundred thousand
dollars and take the house and be
done with let her have her pension uh
relationally i would take option a and
let her have her pension because it's a
clean break
you're not stepping all in each other's
stuff
i don't know if there's such a thing as
a clean break after 32 years but i guess
there is no
but we're also going to be friends but
there's
you know
we don't say i love you as much as we
used to but
yeah that's weird well if you're taking
half of your friend's pension it's going
to hurt that friendship for sure
the thing is i i think you're fine
you're going to be okay and she's going
to be okay um the pension's not that big
it's not that big a deal 100 grand
right now sounds real good uh i'm
staying on a house but i owe 90. now
it's going to be i owe 190 yeah that's
exactly what i would do and then you're
probably not going to keep that house
but basically your trade you're trading
the equity in the house
the majority equity in the house for
uh her pension that's what it amounts to
and that's that's that's the negotiation
that you're proposing and yeah that's
what i would do uh
uh your lawyers your lawyer's
calculation i don't you guys are putting
way too much value on a 1700 pension
it's not that big a deal
it's not that much money thinking but it
is it's not that much money it's not
seventeen thousand it's seventeen
hundred
you make eighty right
but what if something happens to me and
i can't work well you need to get a
disability policy you need to start
saving some dead gun money and setting
yourself up for retirement but that's
you need to do that anyway 1700 one
gonna save your butt or 850 for sure and
you'll save your butt
you know and so y'all are acting like
this pension is some kind of big deal
it's not it's not enough money here to
spit at
it's nice if you send it to me i'll
catch the check but it's not
i'm letting it go
your your plan is the best one on the
table you you've already thought through
this and i'm with you 100 grand
you get the house let her pinch and go
that's what i would do
and she'll take that she's a fool
but there's a lot of fools in divorce
court
a lot of them
a lot of them
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the ramsey show
he's the host of the fine print podcast
very popular podcast you should check it
out at ramsey networks george we got a
good question in by social yeah let's do
this here's the question my husband and
i were blessed with a significant
inheritance after the passing of my
father last year since we have no debt
we would like to give a portion of this
inheritance to each of our three adult
children and we would like to make a
significant donation to a local
non-profit children's home what advice
do you have on how we can do this
without paying additional taxes
wow okay
well i don't know how much it is we
don't have the amount there but we do
know that this year the gift tax amount
is sixteen thousand dollars what that
means is if you give if an individual
gives an individual more than sixteen
thousand dollars it is taxed at the gift
tax rate the amount over
at 55 or 60 percent it's crazy how much
they take so you don't want to violate
that now individual to individuals the
key here
so that means if you got grown kids you
and your husband and your grown kids are
married then there's four individuals
involved so mom can write her son and
her daughter-in-law at two separate
checks for sixteen thousand dad can
write son and daughter-in-law two
separate chicks for sixteen thousand so
we can move sixty four thousand from an
adult couple to an adult couple with
four checks and it'll survive an audit
but don't let anything be more than
sixteen thousand dollars individual to
individual if you do you're going to get
into gift tax or you're gonna have to
check out with your estate tax planning
attorney what's called the unified
estate tax credit meaning you use up
some of your federal exemption with this
gift if you're trying to do if you're
trying to give somebody a couple hundred
thousand dollars that's what you're
gonna do you're gonna step over into
that uh rather than this but most people
can if coupled a couple that 64 000 will
take care of now as far as the
children's home goes that's probably a
501c3 yeah so if you're going to donate
to something like that there are no
limits on how much you can give there's
no sixteen thousand dollar limit you
could give a hundred thousand dollars if
you want and you won't pay additional
taxes for giving to a 501 c three in
fact it can actually lower your taxable
income so this isn't it's tax deductible
it's a tax deductible donation to a
non-profit if it's a verified 501c3 and
so you can take as tax deduction on that
and depending on your income as to how
much the deduction you can use and so
forth some people do standard deductions
some people itemize so i like to work
with the tax pro when it comes to these
situations if it's going to be a large
amount you may be better off itemizing
versus going the standard deduction you
will be you will be if it's a large
amount because you're going to have
given enough that
you're going to get more tax break on
the gift that to this 501 c3 if it's
substantial now if you're giving 5 000
it might not be yeah but if you're
getting like 50 grand 100 grand or
something like that out of this to that
to that children's home then you're
going to want to itemize and you're
going to want to do that with a tax pro
and you're going to want to lay that
down that way and make that happen
because the big thing here is do not let
a tax situation determine your
generosity it's a great benefit to have
your taxes lowered but you know i want
your giving to be from the heart if they
want to do this not because oh we can
you know lower our taxes no it doesn't
determine my generosity but it does
determine uh you you don't want that
spiritually you don't want that
emotionally but you just want to be wise
about it for instance if you wanted to
give your kids um more than 64 000
coupled a couple
uh you might do some of it uh in
december and some of it in january so
you have two different tax years now we
got 128 000
and so you can you know you can if
you're just careful about how you do it
it's not it's just the timing
and the process that you're laying out
there that allows you to do this without
any taxes on it and so just just you
know you don't want to be uh
uh you know one month away eight months
away from saving taxes on something and
so don't determine your generosity but
it could determine the structure
of your generosity how you're going to
go about it and you know we're going to
write four checks instead of just write
one big check you know that kind of
thing and uh and each one be itemized in
the four column
mom to daughter-in-law mom to son you
know names on there so in the event
there's an audit you can come back and
you've got a trail here you got a paper
trail that'll cause you to be able to
survive that gifting yeah process that's
a great question it's very quiet very
detailed very interesting but yeah
uh i often times run into people who
make the mistake of just
um
and it's it's it shows how
philosophically broken our text system
is
that i own something i can't give it to
somebody
without getting screwed you know i mean
that's broken so but i mean a lot of
people don't think
through the taxes and so like a mom will
have a house
and uh she's like 75 and she goes you
know i don't want to leave in the wheel
i'm just gonna go indeed it to junior
huge
tax mistake
you can't just give it away this house
is worth 300 000
if you get audited there's going to be a
you know you're you have tax gift tax
money due on that and and so if you
don't go under the unified estate tax
and go get an estate tax planning uh
someone to help you with the tax
planning on this you can get hammered
and it just feels like you know it's my
house i'd be able to give to my son you
know it's my house i'd be able to give
it to my
the the neighbor down the street i don't
care you know it's mine i ought to be
able to give my stuff away
but no by god if it's not a 501c3 you're
going to get tagged
and uh so you you it's be smart about
this yeah you know the laws work with
the pro understand the situation
it's really important get get you know
get with one of our endorsed local
providers for taxes and get some advice
it's
really there's about three or four
little things you can do where you can
sidestep this stuff if you bother
but if you wait until oh well i've
already deeded it over yeah she's man
you know quickly undo that before
somebody finds it and then go do it
right
you know and it's just uh you get
yourself caught in this sideways big
time it's a big problem
good stuff good stuff thanks for joining
us there by social good things
how would you feel if you knew you could
retire with dignity that you could leave
an inheritance to your family now that'd
be nice the truth is you can have that
kind of life and you can build wealth
and you can become a millionaire
that's what this book baby steps
millionaire is all about that's what
financial peace university is about
that's what premium version of every
dollar is all about
and uh so you know we're about getting
you out of debt so that you can be
generous like we were just talking about
getting you out of debt so that you
change your family tree getting you out
of debt so that you build wealth i don't
want you to be rich so you're a jerk i
want you to be wealthy because you can
do good things with that money when you
get it
outrageous generosity is one of the
things we teach you all the time around
here
so you can use
here what we're doing right now we've
got the best year ever bundle here's the
bundle
access to financial peace university the
premium version of every dollar the two
resources to help you take back control
of your biggest wealth building tool
your income
and a copy of the brand new number one
bestseller baby steps millionaires to
learn the right way to invest and get to
a million dollar net worth
all of this it's called the best year
ever
bundle
and you just go to uh
ramseysolutions.com best that's ramsey
solutions.com best
and um i i just want to do my pip of the
pig i would love to miss your eva there
it is there it is that was pretty good
well i've got granddaughters and so i
didn't know that they they now have an
english accent that's the language you
have because
yeah so uh hillbilly kids with english
accents it's pretty interesting strange
times at the ramsey yes best year ever
so uh that's a good bundle though and
what i love about this even if you're
not in baby step four through six and
you're going well i got a pile of debt
why even read this book what i found
reading this book is it's so much more
than just investing advice yes there's a
little bit of that but there's so much
about belief and mindset and realizing
that it doesn't have to be the way i
thought it had to be
it unlocks some things belief is
everything
it's not just positive thinking stuff i
mean you know zig ziglar is to say um
you know positive thinking will do more
than negative thinking which is true no
question about that but it won't make
you grow three feet it won't make me
have muscles that are big i'm 60 years
old i'm past that issue okay so
um that's not a thing but uh uh
but but here's the thing if you don't
believe that pushing
the button that says start on your car
is gonna cause it to start
then you won't push the button
you know
if you ever sat there when the battery
went dead you go oh
sad since you finally quit believing
that it's going to work right and so you
don't do it anymore but if you know that
when you push the button it's going to
start you would do it and see that's
belief yeah belief causes action you
don't you have to be some kind of
psychologically
you know
john doloni problem right if you if you
acted on things that you didn't believe
to be true yeah it's just like you know
why did you think it was going to work
well
you know but here's the thing
millionaires 97 of them when we
interviewed them
said they believed that you could become
a millionaire
and they went and did it when we
interviewed the general public only 69
believe you can still become a
millionaire and if you think you can or
you think you can't get right henry ford
said you're right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage paul and daley are with
us hey guys how are you doing well how
you doing doing well thanks for having
us we're honored where do you guys live
we live in louisville kentucky all right
welcome to nashville and all the way
down here to do a debt-free scream how
much have you paid off uh 83 000
all right how long did this take 11
months good for you and your range of
income during that time uh 200 to 225.
wow what do you guys do for a living oh
we're both physical therapists ah pt's
good very good
well done guys well done good so i'm
gonna guess and say some of that 83
might have been a little pt student loan
it was all most of it yeah all of it
okay we started it 290s yeah we started
at 290. wow wow and it worked your way
all the way down to 83 before you
started our program yeah so how did you
meet us 11 months ago oh well actually
it's a longer story um we took fpu at
southeast christian yeah in 2013
um yeah like daley said start out with
290 k
um
she's the saver i'm the spender so i
spent the money while she's trying to
save it um fast forward to 2019 um
you're saying you flunked fpu i did i
did she passed successfully i did not
he was pretty good for a few weeks yeah
a couple weeks we did the envelopes and
then i fell off the wagon
so
yeah but fast forward to 2019 uh did my
first excel spreadsheet and was like you
know what we could pay this off uh i
think i gave ourselves the goal of
paying off my student loan by the end of
2020 2021 and then hers by 2023
um then covet hit in 2020.
um started doing some overtime
started paying off more paid off mine
six months early which was awesome um
and then hit hers heavy um and paid off
in november so we finished a year early
just like that yeah so
what
what happened paul i mean
what'd you do with the evil twin well i
think when you when i put together that
spreadsheet um that the interest was in
uh it was in a red negative number we're
kentucky fans and so going against you
know louisville's red yeah i don't want
any only red no we don't and so see so
the lower i could get that red number
the better okay so when i was able to
play around with the numbers and say you
know if i put this much more towards it
that number goes down and so that was my
main motivation put the investing in
blue yeah yeah yeah okay i haven't seen
sports rivalry be a debt-free driver
such a strong motivator right there's a
lot of there's a lot of reasons to get
rid of red and that's right that's
that's not a bad one at all that's not a
bad one at all i'll take anything i can
get if we can get going here so yeah so
uh daley he comes in and says i did a
spreadsheet and i think that you're a
genius what did you say
yeah that's about how that went we had
separate bank accounts at that time um
and he wanted to merge them and i pushed
back pretty heavily against that because
we had everything set so well and it was
going to take a lot of phone calls and
internet things to merge at that point
because all the auto drafts and all that
kind of stuff but i think that probably
helped us the most because we stopped
kind of going at each other like you
know we would send a text and be like
hey we're out of diapers we need can you
get them on the way and he'd be like
well i got them last time it's like
that's a ridiculous thing to
worry about when you're you know making
200 000 a year so it just got to where
enough was enough and wow so the first
time you guys combined bank accounts was
in this debt-free journey yes so yeah
early last year um we got hit with a
surprise uh irs debt off the year before
um and so we sat down at the table and i
said look you know we had the goal of
finishing it by just that by the end of
last year
and then we got hit with that nine
thousand dollar tab that we had to pay
um and we just we we buckled down we she
started taking pt students at work i
worked in the kitchen i worked as a
patient aid i helped my dad build and
repair pools and so just getting it all
together and we were able to do it and
you made it anyway yeah we did wow we
made the go yeah we actually made it
almost a year earlier than we ever
intended to because of all the extra
work but also because of covet overtime
yes yeah kova in a lot of ways i mean
it's been an awful time a lot of times
it was a blast but it helped us out a
lot because you know they were really
short staffed at work so he was able to
pull overtime that he normally isn't
able to do
he had more free time because he was
doing less patient care which enabled
him to really hammer those spreadsheets
so yeah okay so now that you did it what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt is
uh for me it was the budget uh
communication is key um you got to have
a big dream you know our kids are
sitting over there right now so that's
definitely our why
we want to travel as well um
and you gotta you definitely got to you
got to stick to it um we had we had that
irs that we had our furnace go out do
you know how to change a blower motor in
a furnace i'm afraid i do i do as well
thanks to youtube
um so that saved us some money there but
just sticking to it it's easy to make
excuses but if you lean into it and
commit
persevere and keep going wow
so um
paul talked to the guy
that went through fpu and has not done
this spreadsheet yet
how do you get him to do that gosh um
put put the put the opposing team's
colors on it i mean yeah that worked for
me um just sitting down and seeing that
negative balance you know how much money
was going towards interest
it's it's painful to see you know how
much money you're just basically
throwing away um and so that was my big
thing
to try to get out of it faster daily
talk to the people who don't want to
combine accounts
about how inefficient
it is and also how relationally stupid
it is
it was it really was i will say that um
i came from like a family like my
parents had separate accounts still have
separate accounts and they've done fine
it's done it's worked really well for
them but it has worked better i think in
the long run for us to
to put them back together it was a
headache for
a month or two working it out and
figuring it out because like he would
come to me and be like okay how much is
the water bill how much is the lgbt lg e
bill what is this bill where i always
knew all of that because i had been the
one managing it for the last five years
um but i think in the long run it has
really saved a lot a lot of irritation
like a lot of tit-for-tat and a lot of
just like nitpicking at each other of
who's buying what
the diaper thing yeah yeah or dinner you
know like yeah it sounds like more like
roommates than yeah
in a way in a way like that yeah in a
way it was so well you guys are
incredible you're you're not afraid of
work you may have been afraid of doing a
budget and spreadsheet early on but you
guys have never been afraid of work and
that really propelled us honestly yeah
amen that's true well done you guys i'm
proud of you thanks for your help well
done yeah very cool and you brought the
kiddos bring them up one of their names
into ages come on over boys uh so we got
finley here who's six years old
and then we've got sawyer there's three
and finn wanted to say something
go ahead
all right that's okay all right very
cool very cool well we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you that's
the
next chapter in your story for you guys
to go on and be millionaires you're on
your way to do that you got two good
reasons there to change your family tree
very very fun and a copy of total money
makeover for you as well for you to give
away and stir somebody up with paul and
daley finley and sawyer
kentucky 83 000 paid off in 11 months
making 200 to 225 count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream
three three two one say we're done
[Applause]
this is how it's done ladies and
gentlemen
wow
wow just in time for them to rip off the
headsets off off the parents
they were just there is something about
these sports headsets with the
microphone in front that attracts so
much
little kids like nothing you've ever
seen
it's just it's a handle it's supposed to
be grabbed yeah but uh they do a great
job with it so what a cute family very
well done you guys very well done it's
uh man there's some important lessons
there oh yeah you know number one if you
uh didn't get started when you took the
class you still can get started yep not
too late even if you haven't combined
any incomes and combine your money and
working together with the efficiencies
of communication and relationship
efficiencies and even money efficiencies
by combining your accounts you can still
do it yep
a lot of reason to do these things it's
it's never too late to change you know
they say morris coth and todd and her
parents never combine accounts and so
they went i guess we don't need to
combine accounts it worked for them but
it's never too late to decide to do
something different yep yep and they say
you know what if if we're wrong you
could always take them back that's right
but we're not wrong
not yet not yet 100 chance of being
right when you're dave ramsey
wow i'm 100 sure that i'm an expert on
my opinion this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
thanks for joining us america george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today danny is with us in st
louis hi danny how are you
i'm good how are you guys better than we
deserve what's up
hi so i was calling um because my
husband and i are looking for some
advice regarding transitioning our
mindset as we enter baby steps four
through six
okay
so for a little back ground so we got
married in august and we became debt
free in december
thank you
um since then we've finished baby step
three and we've started our 15
um to our retirement plan
but we're struggling with balancing
short-term goals like saving for larger
purchases
versus just living more freely and
starting to enjoy things more now that
we're debt-free
okay
you do have your 15 going into
retirement correct and um
you are committed to finding some money
to throw at the house and get it paid
off and baby step six right
yeah we have a teeny tiny mortgage left
so and that's not a huge concern at this
point okay well i still want to finish
it off so it's still part
baby step six but
so your your issue is just uh enjoying
some fun money
versus purchasing a car in two years
yeah so we've been so i'm 27 and i've
been driving the same car since i turned
16.
so to i'm a little tired of it you need
a car um i need a car what's your
household income
um we make about 175. no you make a lot
of money then okay thank you yeah we do
well so when you when you lay out the
budget and you're having this discussion
with your new husband
um
you you
is there
too much money going on fun or not
enough money going on fun because you
ought to buy a car out of 175 and still
have a lot of fun
yeah i think it's more just that we're
we're balancing them both and we're
doing pretty good saving but i think we
thought it would happen faster because
of how much money we were able to put
towards our debt but now since we've
started like going on weekend trips i
mean we're not being reckless by any
means we're still working our budget and
everything it's just then like we'll
book that flight and then we'll be like
man that money could have gone towards a
car but we really want to enjoy things
too
because it's not an emergency i mean
while i'm tired of my car it runs and it
gets me to work every day
no this is a normal dilemma a lot of
people deal with because you've been so
gazelle intense and now it feels like
well we should be focused on the goals
having fun is not part of the deal but
remember you live like no one else so
that you can live like no one else and
so if i'm you i'm putting it in the
budget and then there's no guilt about
the trip because we budgeted for the
trip yeah that's the thing you're not
doing i think um let's step let's step
back at that a minute and go okay
if we
save if we
allocate
x number of dollars in the budget for
uh weekend travel
let's just give it a category okay
and
having done that we agree we're saving
a thousand dollars a month towards a car
i'm just making up a number two thousand
dollars towards the car whatever the
number is okay
um
and then you go and you spend what you
said you were going to spend on weekend
travel not more
then there would be no pull
so that tells me you're not allocating
these things until after the fact
yeah i think i'm more tempted to be like
okay well let's see how little we can
live off of um yeah but i mean if you
put it down the budget you have that
discussion before the money leaves them
before the trip happens
okay
you and your husband are sitting and
looking at it on the paper and you're
going okay this is what we're spending
on this this is how i solve the problem
with my wife because she is a tight wide
and she would not spend money on herself
afterwards after we got through went
through all that hell bankruptcy and
everything and we had no trouble
allocating clothing money
for the family but she would spend a
hundred percent of it on the kids and be
scared of o'hara i'll just wear the
drapes
you know
and uh which is a bunch of crap and so
finally i had we had to break it out to
where we had a separate envelope for
sharon's clothes
to make her spend money on herself on
sharon's clothes
and uh that kind of helped her almost
heal
from this tight-fisted
trauma that we had been through right
that causes your fist to be so tight and
so we went from intense to intentional
and said uh okay this money the money in
this envelope it says sharon's clothes
cannot be spent on anything except for
sharon's clothes
and you know what you wanna know what's
weird we still have that envelope
that's weird i just thought of that
that's weird wow we should stop that she
has plenty clothes but um oh my gosh but
i mean the point was that what exactly
what you're experiencing
was uh you know you're going okay i want
to be more mature but i also want to
have fun i mean you know while we're
going on this trip we should not do that
we should just still be gazelle intense
and
but if you lay it out and you and and
you put a name on it and you say this
money is to be spent on weekend travel
it can't be spent on your car it's
already spent so i spent it's been on
paper it's gone
like insurance closed the money's gone
you can't spend it on anything else it's
already been labeled insurance closings
disassociate yourself emotionally and
say hey this two thousand dollars for
the weekend trip this is not car money
so we're not gonna see it as money that
could go towards the car and when it's
part of the this is a great discussion
by the way and and and when it's part of
the overall budget you say okay that
means we're putting i'm
making up whatever number it is you can
make up whatever you want danny but two
thousand dollars a month on the car okay
and so i'm still gonna get the car at
christmas
i'm still going to get the 15 000 car at
christmas i mean still gonna get it and
so i'm i'm it's not knocking me off of a
reasonable goal now yes i could get the
car in august instead of december by
doing no travel but we're making the
adult decision to be intentional and say
we're doing some weekend trips make
under seventy five thousand dollars
and it's gonna slow down my car a little
bit but i'm still getting the car so i'm
still being an adult
we're not out of control but i think you
gotta label it and release
it okay yeah
that that's what we
i it took me back to a memory from 30
years ago almost you know for me to do
that but that's that's that's a really
good question
and the other thing you got to do is you
have to follow the narrative of we went
we're going from intense when we leave
baby step three to intentional
okay yeah we go from sprinting to
marathon
yeah one through three is a sprint we're
running from the cheetah we're trying to
keep from getting killed we're getting
the mess cleaned up get the emergency
fund in place then three or four five
and six is a marathon we slow down
because it's a longer run we're pacing
ourselves we're keeping the nutrition
the hydration coming we're going to
finish this 13 and a half this is 26.2
we're you know 13.1 or 26.2 we're going
to finish here and we're going to finish
it up we gotta have a plan to do it all
the way out and i can't you know i can't
sprint uh until i see the tape yeah and
if i got a little left i'll sprint that
last little bit but that's it and so
yeah go ahead and knock that house out
go and get that car bought go ahead and
buy that couch or fix up that kitchen or
you budget those things and you go okay
this month i'm going to be able to do
this month over here in the future if i
label this and then you label the fun
money and you're released of guilt yeah
if you look down at your budget and
you're in baby step four through six and
there's not fun things on there then
you're doing it wrong that's not the
plan the plan is not just be gazelle
intense forever and have no fun because
dave said so they didn't say that you
gotta do this stuff and so put it in the
budget and if even if you have to force
yourself and go we're gonna go on
weekend trips we're gonna have a date
night budget look down to where there's
things you're excited about as a couple
that you look forward to doing that's in
your budget uh that's going to help you
release some of this and you guys are
doing great you have more emotional
maturity and financial maturity than
most of america so know that you're not
doing anything wrong by not putting it
all towards the car but it's it's a
common struggle me and my wife struggle
with this as we paid off the house dave
because you want to be gazelle and we
wanted to pay it off so badly that it
was always going well
when you get there and you finish it's
surreal yeah but then there's also
almost like this confusion
because you you do have to she set it at
the early in the call you do have to
switch a gear yeah you got to downshift
from intense to intentional
and then label it and labeling the money
means it has to be spent on that
releases you to do that
and uh early in the budgeting process
you'll you'll experience that same kind
of a thing when you do your budget the
first time and you actually label this
number of dollars is for food
so when you go to the grocery store you
don't have this
angst this knot in your stomach like
when i buy food am i really is the
electricity going to get cut off
because i i didn't pay the electric bill
no because you got the electric wheel
covered in the budget and you've got
this much allocated for food covered in
the budget and so you get this sense of
peace a sense of power when you start
doing the written plan you get on your
every dollar app and you start running
your budget out yeah there's amazing
freedom in there so it's the same thing
though that label and release
label and release release the emotion
around it label it it has to be used for
that whatever you labeled it unless you
come back and reset the whole budget
good discussion really good really good
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host my co-host
today ramsay personality george campbell
host of the fine print ramsay network
production a whole season of that
podcast now in the books you should dial
over to where podcasts are found and
listen through the fine print you'll
learn a lot george does a great job with
that we talking today is always about
your relationships
your money
your career and your work
and you the phone number here is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
trevor is in new york city hi trevor
welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave hey george happy best seller
day
thank you sir we appreciate that yeah
how can we help today
yeah so i have a question regarding uh
my uh student loan i took out probably
about seven years ago um i i went to
college when uh wasn't able to do it
without taking out loans but obviously
now i wish i could have but um
back in uh that time we had a co-signer
go on to that loan it was uh a family
member um they didn't really want to do
it and it proved uh to kind of be like a
point of contention and
nothing bad ever happened with it so far
and now that i'm in baby step two fast
forward to today
um i've been paying off uh all that
all my lone snowball style and
my question is being that that's kind of
part of my why i recently received a
cosine release application for that loan
um and i was curious what you guys
thought about if i should
go ahead and act on that cosigner
release why are they offering to release
the cosigner i've never heard of that
because it's been a certain amount of
time since um i've been paying on the
loan now for like two or three years
um so after
i think it's 24 months they offer you to
be able to drop them as a co-signer drop
them
why wouldn't you okay
because that's kind of part of my why as
to why i want to pay it off and like
it's kind of giving me my intensity to
go hardcore
um
so
in essence like i could take them off
but then i also feel like that would
kind of halt my progress a little bit my
motivation why would it halt the
progress what's the motivation behind
having the cosigner on there
because by
having them on there it makes me want to
pay it off even more
to prove to them that it was possible to
start with and that it was uh
it was a i know it wasn't a good
decision at the time but that i was
trustworthy with that decision yeah
um the student loan is not going to do
that you're going to do that with the
way you live your life
the you know you're trying to you're
trying to make the student loan work too
hard in this relationship
it doesn't have the ability it does not
have the ability to make this person
respect you
yeah so no i'm rea
i i i think you can manage your own
motivation the fact that you can ask the
question tells me that you can manage
your own motivation
and uh you need to let them go as soon
as possible for their sake your sake the
sake of the relationship plus there's no
point in having them on there i mean it
lowers the risk of the overall situation
i love it yeah get rid of them
definitely yeah i didn't even know they
did this i've never heard of it so
that's awesome yeah
yeah
um yeah because i figured it'll be paid
off within the next two and a half
anyway but um
release them and then you just be uh you
just man up and say all right i gave up
my
bitterness motivation so i have to have
a new motivation
yeah a more positive one let's just get
a noble one that's not
me pissed off at somebody and i'll show
you yeah if anything's going to show
them it's you removing them as a
co-signer well that means going you know
no that just lets him go it doesn't show
that he's reliable sure to his point but
but you know that uh
yeah find something else to motivate you
that was my instinct was you need a
bigger why than the chip on the shoulder
yeah you got the family that's it that
was it that's it but i love the spirit
of it the intensity you've got to pay
this thing off but don't let the family
member be the motivation you need a
bigger why man you got to do it for
yourself
yeah i mean if they can't look at you
and say look you know trevor paid off
all his loans
while he was doing it he let me off
and
gosh i i always wondered if he was going
to do it and he did it he and it proved
it if they can't do that
without being a co-signer they can't do
it while they are a co-center yeah
they're just going to be that guy
they're just going to be the twerp the
rest of whoever this is they're just
going to be a twerp and so
that you know you're asking the student
loan to
give you the power to make them respect
you and it does not give you that power
you being you you manning up you taking
care of business is you put you in a
seat that should be respected and then
it's their choice whether they're gonna
do that or not
so don't ask this situation to do that
for you
uh and that that's how i would look at
it but it's a it got you started we'll
give it that but at least it got you
started good catalyst there's nothing
wrong with having a a a a little bit of
a selfish or
negative reason for getting started but
then you don't keep going i mean when i
got started i got started because i
pissed off at american express but you
know i'm still pissed off at him but
it's not my motivation anymore yeah you
know
anger is a good start but it's got to
turn into excitement about your future
there you go good good marcus is with us
in l.a hey marcus what's up
hey mr ramsay how you doing better than
i deserve how can we help
yeah so i wonder if you guys can help me
out uh me and my wife we're due for
about our first kid within the next
couple weeks
congratulations we
yeah appreciate it we have a a regular
vehicle that i use to get to and from
work
and uh with this uh fourth kia coming
we're definitely going to need a new
vehicle to be able to accommodate the
extra child you only have one kid you
only have one vehicle
yes yes sir we have one vehicle okay and
what's it worth
uh we would say fair market value about
five thousand dollars okay
and what is it
oh it's just a regular sedan a afford
okay so you sell that you sell a five
thousand dollar sedan and you buy a five
thousand dollar minivan
okay
is that simple leaves you in exactly the
same place you were but it's got seats
yes sir and she ain't gonna be pretty
but that'll give you motivation to
upgrade as you get through baby step two
and have some a carrot dangle in there
in front of you but it'll get you from a
to b
okay that's what i was looking for we
just wanted to know yeah because we were
just like okay the mark is crazy for all
these vehicles and they look like
they're up about twenty percent plus
something they are but you're selling
one in that market too
gotcha so you're selling a sedan that's
not a great vehicle and you're gonna buy
a van that's not a great vehicle
oh that makes a lot of sense but but
you're gonna but george's point is
you're not gonna stay there
this is just this is just how you're
gonna get out of debt and we're gonna
get ourselves moving and get this baby
step two finished then we're gonna get a
better car and
honestly after baby step three it is
what a whole lot of people do they have
a they've been driving some kind of
freaking hoopty and they do a move up
after baby step three
a lot i don't know what the percentage
is but it's north of fifty percent of
people yeah well
and you know i love a good deal
georgia's just gonna drive you just got
your house you got you know what dave
let me borrow one of your cars for a
little while
you won't miss it too much
i'll take your course it's not about my
car i will take your worst car
this is about your car you don't like it
when it's flipped on you no it's not i
have good cars it's not flipped on me
there's no flip at all here you got one
to let me borrow it'll be all right i
got a spare but you you're just cheap
yeah right you're just cheap george we
landed there thank you this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me 130 000 all
thanks to what i learned at bethel tech
you could be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today if you've been paying
attention in the real estate market
you've noticed the competition out there
is high
in part because available inventory is
low
when inventory is low it simply means
there are more buyers than sellers
and that turns the pressure up and
drives the prices up and it makes it
hard to snag a right house sellers want
to accept the right offer this is not
amateur hour just because a house will
sell quick does not mean you need to do
this on your own it's a good way for you
to screw this up you need to have a pro
by your side if you're buying in this
weird market you need to have a pro by
your side if you're selling in this
weird market you could really miss out
on tens of thousands of dollars if you
don't it's a problem the agents that we
endorse our endorsed local providers
have years of industry success they're
not going to compromise your financial
goals
their pulse rate doesn't change they're
not running around like a chicken with
their head cut off trying to get a deal
done they're going to walk with you and
go easy boy easy boy that's how you do
this it's how you get the most money
when you're selling it this is how you
get the best deal when you're buying it
you can instantly connect with one of
these endorsed local providers in your
area
just go to
ramseysolutions.com agent
that's a ramsey trusted agent you'll
find one near you
right there in your neighborhood
ramsey solutions dot com slash
agent our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they are the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible deal today's question
comes from britain in utah my wife and i
are in our early 20s and make about 140k
per year with no other debt other than
our home wow we expect our income to
increase once i graduate college in a
few months how do i calculate the proper
amount of life insurance if we expect
our income to go up drastically over the
next 15 to 20 years wow good problem to
have in this situation it's amazing
looks like there's only one person
working and they got 140k coming in so
it's a good question though people think
you know if i get my life insurance my
term we recommend term life 10 to 12
times your income
and people go okay well if i get that in
place what happens if my life changes my
income goes up mine goes down so it's a
valid question and our friends is xander
they deal with this stuff all the time
but
you can change yep the amount of term
life you have yep you can buy some more
and that's the thing to do just buy what
you need now 15 to 20 year level and
then later on you can buy some more 15
to 20 year level
and that's what i've ended up doing and
here's what's strange
uh it's not true at this moment in my
life
but there was a period of time over 15
or 20 years that i was buying policies
ever so often new ones to add to the
coverage and some of them were starting
to drop off
during that time
life insurance became so competitive
that the rates dropped
and i was buying life insurance 10 years
later for the same price wow although
i'm 10 years older
and so it's still it's still very very
competitive and there's still a pressure
in the marketplace in that direction but
it's not like that in today but uh the
point is it's not going to cost if
you're 20 early 20s so let's call them
24. okay and if you go back 10 years
later at 34 and you add a policy it's
not gonna be a bazillion dollars
difference it is different but the
difference in a 24 year old and a 34
year old is not it's not it's just not
it's not 50 or something it's not that
kind of thing so you're not going to see
that much difference so just add
policies as you need
that'll lengthen the time you have
coverage by the way
uh if you do the 15 to 20 year every
time and 10 years later you do a 15 to
20 years so you've got another
10 years on the plan now if you need it
and uh and that's what i have done
throughout my
career and uh
and then you know
at
this point i don't need life insurance
we have some and the joke has always
been because swi sharon wants it but
those policies are dropping off i
dropped two of them uh two weeks ago
they hit the end and i'm not renewing
them
and so uh you know you just change them
out and i'm 61. i obviously don't need
life insurance uh but uh
that's what will happen is you just keep
adding and what you're doing is you're
kind of parlaying this and layering it
out yeah and it's important to remember
what life insurance is for to replace
your income for people that depend on it
and we've gotten questions that do i
need life insurance on my baby and you
know i keep life insurance until i die
and we always talk about you don't need
life insurance if you follow our plan
once that 15 to 20 years up you've got a
paid for house you're on your way to
becoming a millionaire
you're gonna be self-insured to where
you're not no one's gonna need to roll
on your income they can use you know the
money from the life insurance if
something did happen within the policy
and invest that and peel the money off
to live off of so it's a great plan and
it's it's worked for millions and
millions of people
josh is with us josh is in huntington
west virginia hi josh how are you
i'm doing great mr ramsey how are you
better than i deserve what's up
uh yes sir um first of all i want to
thank you for your plan because of that
my wife and i we are completely dead
free with a paid-for house wow and um
look at you man
yeah we're we're 35 and we've had our
house paid off for
almost six years
so
i love it man um anyway
thank you sir um anyway i don't want to
take up much of your time but
when we're doing our budget i know you
know you do zero based budget what comes
into the paychecks you put that down
and but what happens like with your
savings if you've got
um savings like if i make a new budget
now for february but we've got savings
and i want to make a purchase so say
we're going to purchase a flight for a
trip
i don't want how do i put that savings
into that budget without
because if i book the flight without
putting the savings in and it blows up
my budget how do i get that
strategically to account for the savings
our extra cash
above and beyond our investments and
everything else how do i budget all that
out to not blow up the budget
well i guess there'd be two types of
purchases you're doing they're a very
large and then a small purchase booking
of flights a small purchase and let's
say you booked a three thousand dollars
worth of airline tickets uh and you had
the money set aside for your trip and
it's in your trip savings and so you
just move the savings over and you're
checking and it shows up and you drop it
into the budget as income for that month
and uh and you know you just integrate
it in a large purchase would be that you
you know you saved up 30 000 bucks to
buy a car
i'm probably not running that through
the budget i'm just going to write a
check for that
and the just because it comes out of
checking account doesn't mean it has to
come out of the budget
okay all right that makes it easier i
was freaking out because it was blowing
up my budget every time we did that and
it was kind of stressful
i guess the difference is if you're
using a debit card and it's showing up
automatically in your every dollar
then you're gonna move the money that's
a smaller purchase and you're going to
move that money out of savings over into
your budget as income
so that it doesn't blow your budget up
that's what's happening with an airline
ticket purchase right but my point is
you're buying a car you're probably
wiring the money into the dealership or
cashier's check or something like that
and so you're not necessarily running it
through every dollar if as long as
you're not running through your every
dollar budget then you're you're not
going to run into this issue yeah the
simplicity of just saying all right i've
got three thousand dollars for this trip
i'm gonna move it from savings to
checkings that now counts as income
that's then allocated to that trip in
the budget yep so
you got a vacation line item in your
every dollar at that point you fund it
from the top as income and then it's
sitting there oh and by the way when you
write the airline ticket that's fine oh
when you go on the trip and you go to
dinner that's out of that same one you
know and you allocate it over there and
you're just you're it's a little
miniature budget inside the budget yeah
for your trip yeah for the trip it's
your travel trip well that's great
they're they're doing the stuff i mean
that's impressive man 29 years old
they're
very well done that's that's beautiful i
mean the guy's on his way to be in
serious serious wealth yeah and uh
here's the thing about all that
it's a great question i'm glad he asked
it because it's good to get these little
nuanced things these little issues where
you get that where the thing starts just
running like a machine where you just
don't have to think about it you get you
get it on autopilot the machine runs you
start the car it runs right and you
simulate your financial plan you started
it runs and your systems or you have
systems and processes in place that run
and you do need to get those tuned in
but here's the thing
all that means is you're paying
attention
and 98 of the people that don't win it's
not because of a nuance in the system
it's because they ain't even paying
attention
this guy's beyond paying attention he
paid off his house at 29. he's beyond
dialed in he's nerding out on the budget
now yeah it's a good problem to have
well it's just we're dialing in
processes here and just take heart those
of you that are doing this and if you're
getting caught up on something small
like that just smile
enjoy the ride for figuring out how to
make the machine run a little bit
smoother but you're fine because you're
paying
attention broke people don't ask these
questions that's what it comes down to
exactly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage paige
is with us hey paige how are you good
how are you good welcome welcome where
do you live
salt lake city utah well it's a long way
to nashville yeah always an excuse to
come to nashville right hey i hear you
any excuse we're glad you're here nice
and cold for you so how much debt have
you paid off 25 137
good for you and how long did that take
six months wow kicking it and your range
of income during that time 58 to 70.
okay and uh what kind of debt was the 25
all student loans all right yeah all
right what's your degree in
experience design and management with
emphasis in non-profit management okay
wow good so what do you do for a living
i am an event marketing manager actually
just got a new job started a couple
weeks ago all right good yeah that's a
good good use of that knowledge there
huh yeah very good
all right fun so how long you been out
of school um three years in april okay
what made you decide six months ago to
turn this on and do this ramsey stuff
well
it kind of started before that of like
when i graduated i would just lay awake
at night thinking about these student
loans because
i just hated that they were there
and i didn't really know how to tackle
them especially because when i got out
of college i was making 50 and it just
felt like that's half of my income that
i need to pay off and the principles
were so high that every time i paid the
next month i felt like it was the same
exact balance it was so it was really
disheartening
and then covet happened there was no
interest and one of my friends randomly
had mentioned that they listened to the
ramsay show and i was like i've never
actually listened to that so i started
listening to the podcast
and i was like wait i should budget
and so
i started a realization
yeah yeah i was working from home and so
i was listening to every single podcast
every single day it just really lit a
fire underneath me and i just set a goal
that i would be done by september of
2020 and on september 1st of 2020 i paid
off the last of the balance she hit the
goal yep just like that ding ding
exactly that simple wow was awesome well
and so you used the fact that there was
no interest during that time and you
budgeted and you leaned in and did your
income go up early in the process or
late in the process i'm kind of in the
middle so i started trying to look at
different side hustle things of
something i heard on the podcast a lot
and so i've always had an interest in
interior design so i actually started
taking on a couple clients and redoing
homes
and so that helped bring in about 12k on
top of my income wow very good
that was a huge piece of it i was
getting more one more use of your degree
yeah i mean your this all of your income
looked like it was going towards debt i
was going to ask if there was some kind
of side hustle involved here yeah
definitely a side hustle wow
very impressive or is this something you
want to keep doing or is it you're like
i'm done for now no i actually i love it
i'm continuing to take clients and
hopefully we'll transition that to a
full-time career in the future wow turn
into a business yeah for you yeah fun
how does it feel to be free it's the
best thing i can go to sleep at night
without these fears of losing a job and
having this debt to pay off so it's been
it's been the best i've just been so
happy and trying to get everyone to
understand the joy of not having any
debt yeah
yeah cool who was your biggest
cheerleader along the way um i had a lot
of them i had some really great friends
actually one of my friends when i told
her hey i've started listening to dave
ramsey podcast um i got an amazon box in
the mail and it was the total money
makeover book oh wow but the note said
love lebron james because i'm a huge
lebron james fan and so it took months
for me to figure out who it was
um but
lebron james sent you books that's your
friend i did too i was gonna say yeah
lebron james got me involved he got you
a total money makeover book did this
happen not okay yeah and then my family
has been super awesome and supportive so
just had a lot of people along the way
all right fun
fun awesome fun okay now because you you
can't it's hard to do this and not talk
about it so when somebody says okay okay
okay okay okay okay shut up
how did you do it you pay off 25 000 in
six months making 58 you didn't make 25.
obviously half of it was a side hustle
you kicked in that's the way the numbers
work right
and uh but
what do you tell people they say okay
how'd you do what do you do to get out
of debt you said you tell them what the
two things for me one the law of tithing
um being a religious person i just know
that like being committed to that that
christ always
assists us and helps make up the
difference and the second is budgeting
obviously goes hand in hand with that of
just making sure that when you actually
know where your money's going you
realize you have so much more money than
you think you do because i'm not just
going to target every weekend and
dropping
money on random stuff at target so yeah
which is all target has
a black hole with one with one eye full
of random stuff
wow you're very impressive so here's
what i want to know paige talk to the
person who maybe is like you but they're
going well i mean student loan
forgiveness is going to happen and i
mean there's no interest there's no
payments why would you even make a
payment and instead you went now i'm
making extra payments i want this out of
my life what do you say to that person i
think that when we wait for other things
to happen to make it so that our life is
easier we're end up going to be waiting
a lot longer than we think we do and i
think that it's just so much more
instead of being told like oh actually
you don't need to pay this
i feel so much more
like i just feel a better human being
and i have more control over my money
because i know that like no i'm the
master of my own finances and i'm not
gonna wait for the government to tell me
that like oh you're forgiven you don't
need to worry about this anymore it's
just like get it out of the way and move
on with your life and take that next
step to becoming a millionaire
mic drop
wow
she says it was such a sweet voice i
know
it's like freedom
yeah but yeah i mean
like there's a take take your destiny by
the throat yes that's it yes that's
exactly what you did yeah that's very
good most people don't even think it's
possible they don't think they can get
control and you just decided one day
that no i'm going to be in control i'm
going to be the master of my money yeah
that's incredible we're so proud of you
how many debt-free screams do you think
you've watched um
probably like at least 300. whoa
i watched a lot i listened to a lot of
dave ramsey you're inside of one that's
so better well now so now i was just
thinking because now you are that for
someone because you were laying awake
and somebody said check this out you
tile in the podcast and it's like this
is a strange strange podcast strange
radio show
and then i'm actually going to pull up
youtube and watch some of these people
do their debt free screams and then
now that's you yeah that's a pretty cool
trans process there that you've gone
through very neat very proud of you
thank you well done very well done how's
it how's it feel to be free again
amazing
the best all right we got a copy of the
brand new number one best seller baby
steps millionaires for you how ordinary
people built extraordinary wealth and
how you can too
and i'll also give you a copy of the
total money makeover and you can ship it
to lebron james perfect
because he might need it you never know
probably not but okay paige from salt
lake city utah 25 000 paid off in six
months megan 58 to 70
plus the old uh home interior side
hustle very well done all right paige
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
one two three i'm debt free
yeah
and a trip to nashville boom there you
go just like that
why not this is the time to do it it
works man it works
what an impressive young woman yeah
inspiring she's gonna inspire a lot of
people that were like her
so you know it it's
she she just said i don't want to lay
awake at night
this is you know
it's amazing how much
real estate in our brain
how much free rent in our brain
that we give
these negative things
and uh the bible talks about taking
every thought captive
and really in a sense that's what she
issued i'm not living like this
and uh underneath that uh sweet voice
and demeanor there's a warrior in there
there's a lot of grit a lot of grit
that's a good word a lot of warrior
and uh she moved
you know
looked in the mirror and said i can do
this yeah and my generation is just
plagued with anxiety and fears and
cynicism and it's just your generation
it's only yours and gen z but especially
ours dave we love to complain
everything's everyone else's problem and
we can't do anything to it it just
happens to us
we just have social media now so we can
just blast it a lot more than you guys
could you know you get to have an
opinion but but other than that but i
mean every every generation's had this
yeah it's not it's uh i mean
in recent in recent memory in the last
50 years boomers too yeah even those
horrible boomers that's right thank you
for saying it out loud yeah we're all
thinking it but it's amazing what
happens when you get control of your
money how much of that can go away and
you're not cynical anymore the anxiety
goes away you can sleep at night
even the boomers
[Music]
even though they don't deserve to
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today psalm 34 19 the
righteous person may have troubles but
the lord delivers him from them all
thomas paine said the harder the
conflict the more glorious the triumph
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
and your money it's a free call triple
eight eight two five five
two two five you jump in and we will
talk uh karen is in washington dc hi
karen how are you
great how are you dave better than i
deserve how can i help
well i am on baby step two paying off
debt
um i have credit card debt of about 25
000 left and then i have three mortgages
um
one mortgages of rental property that
i've had since 1998
and
the other is
my primary care and then my mother um
passed and left me one that we
um have a mortgage on
my dilemma is i recently lost my job
and i'm 64 and i was wondering
sell out and retire
rather than try to
continue
with another job
you have uh no money saved though
well i have a 401k um of about 310
000. oh that's helpful okay good i feel
a whole lot better now
all right
and um okay what's the house worth that
your your mom left you
um it's probably a worth about
150. what do you owe on
and uh oh on that 29 000.
okay all right and what about the other
rental what do you owe on it
the rental i owe um 145
000 on what's it worth
it's probably worth at least 200
000 um
or maybe 225
it's not in the best condition i've
rented out the hood since 1998. you said
we earlier are you married
no i'm single okay
all right and your personal residence
what do you owe on it
214 on it
okay
and um what is it worth
it's probably worth about
300 um
300
maybe 325. okay 340 is acceptable last
year
well let me ask you this okay um
i think if i were in your shoes
i would want a real clean
and simple
life
which would lead me to selling
your mom's house and the rental and
paying your house off with the proceeds
you can get enough out of those two to
pay your house off
then you got three you have a paid for
house no bills
you got those twenty five thousand
credit cards you need to chop those
things up and you know you're going to
get some money together and get those
get rid of those whether you take it out
of your nist egg or whether you just
scrape it together and get them knocked
out but that's not that's not keeping
you from retiring you get it you
i want those two things i want the
credit cards paid off and i would take
the money from the sale of the other two
houses and pay your house off and just
breathe this in for a second because i
know i just sold your mom's house and i
know you got a tear in your eye when i
did that okay but
breathe this in for a second you're
sitting there in your house
it's the only thing you have to repair
you have to deal with repairs you don't
have to deal with tenants
you have to deal with insurance and
taxes you got your house and it's paid
for
and you've got 300 000 in your nest egg
and you've got your social security
coming in
i think you're going to be okay if you
do that
okay
how does that feel
how's that it feels really
a big relief off of me building
i think if you i think if you go back to
work you're going back to work to keep
those other two houses that you probably
shouldn't keep
right you're right you're right
yeah so get in touch with one of our
endorsed local providers on the real
estate
and have them help you get those things
listed and let's get them sold there's
there's something to be said for
simplicity in our lives
for just cleanliness
yeah it's definitely uh underrated and a
lot of people especially when you're 64
and you've got all these mortgages and
you lost the job it just adds all of the
stress into your life and when i'm 64 i
want to be relaxed more relaxed than
i've ever been and that's what i want
for our friend karen here yeah i can see
you draining down that 310 trying to
keep those rental those other properties
propped up yeah it just sounds like a
mess to deal with yeah i don't know it
doesn't sound like she loves any of them
i i think i talked her into it that was
pretty easy that might have been your
best sales pitch i mean i i'm shocked
because i sold her mom's house that's a
hard one well you are a good salesman
and you've been in real estate a long
time
you've got a future in this yeah you
think it'll work out for me all right
nathan's in salt lake city hey nathan
what's up
hi dave hi george how you guys doing
good how can we help
uh so i just had a question about what
we should be doing next with our money
so me and my wife we just had a new baby
in november congratulations
thank you
and we have just finished our baby step
3 with our fully funded emergency fund
yay but i'm still in university ah
thanks
i'm still in university i have two years
left
so i wasn't sure if we should continue
on to four five and six and
start investing in retirement and doing
the 529 for the baby or if we should
just be
like what we should be doing at this
point
are you able to cash flow the rest of
your school
we should be able to i haven't had to
spend any money on school so far i have
a full academic scholarship and then we
get the pell grant in as well
okay what is your household income
i make about 44 000 a year before tax so
okay and what's your degree gonna be in
it's biochemistry but i'm planning on
going to medical school after so it'll
be more school
okay all right
i think we invest in you right now i
think you got your emergency fund you
got clearer debt and i think you just
keep piling up as much money as you can
pile up
for school
because your best rate of return is
going to be on nathan
yeah
so would you recommend putting that in
an index fund or should we just have it
in the bank or would you suggest
you know some mix of that probably but
uh the money you're going to be leaving
alone for a long time you can drop it
into an index fund but how old are you
guys
uh we're both 22 me and my wife okay
yeah
i mean if you drop it into an index fund
you're gonna be fine and just just load
it up and just i won't see how big a
pile of money you can get man i mean
you're not it's not gonna be a huge pile
because you're making forty four
thousand but
um anything we can do to make a dent in
this medical school is going to be the
way to go yeah i'd want to avoid any
kind of student loans and the house and
all that stuff that's great and the
college that can come later that's all
yeah the college for the kid you get
that no trouble you could go be an md um
and
you know buying a house i wouldn't worry
about buying a house right now
right now that this is game on for
nathan
you're 22 you're still super young
you've got all kinds of time here to do
all this stuff and the other things the
other acquisitions and the other
processes
if you're a debt-free doctor you're
going to be able to do all of that
easily and not be stressed because
you're not going to have 300 000 in
student loans then trying to go i got to
buy a house i got to do all these things
yeah good question man thank you for
joining us
i think it's a good idea to remember um
we are huge believers in buying and
owning a house
but we do not agree
with what most people will tell you in
the culture which is by one right this
second everybody ought to buy a house
buy house buy a house buy a house buy a
house by house you ought to be out of
debt
you got to have the emergency fund in
place
and you ought to be stabilized
meaning that you're not you know
finishing up something where you're
going to be jumping cities
um and
because jumping in and out of houses is
super expensive
and so buying a house is a good idea
when you've done those things
but uh but everybody should not buy a
house yeah no matter you know broke
people buying a house it makes you
broker it does not make you anything
else that's why they call them brokers
but uh it's just i see it all the time
people in their 20s and their 30s and
they go well there's two things either
outside pressure that's going hey you
should buy a house what are you doing
you're an idiot or it's pride where you
go i i deserve a house yeah and both
horns or it's fomo all right yeah houses
are going up i gotta go i gotta get in i
gotta get it i gotta get it i gotta get
in for the for the i'm gonna get priced
out of the market i gotta get in and
none of those things are true yeah none
of those things are true you'll get
there you'll get there patience
grasshopper
[Laughter]
i wonder who knows what that means no
one knows uh i don't know i do
i do oh my goodness that puts this hour
of the ramsey show in the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermzyshow.com
[Music]
you